[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf uns marietta slomka und
die ukraine feiern den untergang moskaus
so heißt ja das russische kriegsschiff
das die ukraine nach eigenen angaben
letzte nacht versenkt oder zumindest
schwer getroffen hat die russische seite
hingegen spricht nur davon dass an bord
munition explodiert sei was sein
eingeständnis von groben fehlern der
besatzung wäre aber offenbar immer noch
besser als zugeben zu müssen dass man
abgeschossen wurde die moskwa ist nicht
irgendein schiff sie ist oder war der
stolz der russischen marine hinzu kommt
dass um die moskwa bereits eine andere
ukrainische helden geschichte rankt sie
soll jenes schiff sein dass in den
ersten kriegstagen eine vorgelagerte
insel ansteuerte und die dort
stationierten ukrainischen soldaten
aufforderte sich zu ergeben deren
kolportierte antwort ging um die welt
russian worship go [ __ ] yourself das ist
ein crash berichtet
sie graben sich ein und erwarten den
russischen ansturm ukrainische soldaten
nordwestlich mariupol regen und schlamm
aber die moral der kämpfer scheint
intakt
wir werden dafür sorgen dass das hier
nicht wird wie in mariupol wir halten
stand
an einer anderen front vermeldet das
ukrainische militär heute einen
bedeutsamen erfolg der russische
raketenkreuzer moskwa hier
archivaufnahmen bei einem seemanöver im
schwarzen meer vor allem jahr soll sagt
die ukraine bei einem ukrainischen
angriff schwer beschädigt worden sein
im operationsgebiet wurde das
flaggschiff moskwa von einer anti
schiffs raketen getroffen und schwer
beschädigt ein feuer ist ausgebrochen
andere schiffe wollten helfen aber die
starken explosionen der munition haben
den kreuzer gekippt und er beginnt zu
sinken
die ukraine hieß es aber das schiff mit
der selbst entwickelten anti schiffs
raketen neptun angegriffen
der angriff wurde offenbar unterstützt
durch die in der türkei entwickelte
kampfdrohne bayraktar die für zahlreiche
militärische erfolge der ukraine
verantwortlich gemacht wird die drohne
hier präsentiert bei einer militärparade
in kiew belegt den hohen technischen
standard viele ukrainischer
waffensysteme
russland dementierte dass der kreuzer
gesunken sei von einem großen brand war
die rede die besatzung habe das schiff
verlassen man plane die maske
abzuschleppen auf die krim sollte die
maske sinken ist das flaggschiff der
schwarzmeerflotte für russlands marine
nicht zu ersetzen denn die zufahrt zum
schwarzen meer der bosporus bleibt vom
nato mitglied türkei für russische
kriegsschiffe gesperrt die maske von
hoher symbolkraft hat es schon bis auf
eine ukrainische briefmarke geschafft
die den widerstand ukrainischer soldaten
gegen die russische marine würdigt auf
der schlangen insel nach odessa
unterdessen weitere zum teil wahllose
raketenangriffe der russischen armee wie
hier auf einen städtischen
vergnügungspark in rage
im noch umkämpften mariupol bleiben
trümmer zurück für russlands armee
einmarschierte irgendwo mittendrin sitzt
valentina britney war
warum zerstören sie uns warum
13 stöckige häuser sind hier ausgebrannt
die menschen sitzen im keller ohne
toilette eines der häuser ist jetzt
eingestürzt und 19 menschen sind tot
weite teile der hafenstadt sind
inzwischen unter russischer kontrolle
doch es gibt noch immer ukrainischen
widerstand
tim krüger ist für uns in kiew wenn es
stimmt dass dieses schiff schwer
beschädigt ist also außer gefecht was
könnte das für die kriegsszenen dort
unten an der küste bedeuten
also wenn es wirklich so ist dass die
der raketenkreuzer moskwa so schwer
beschädigt ist dass er in diesem krieg
nicht mehr eingreifen kann dann denke
ich wäre das ein erheblicher schlag für
die russischen streitkräfte denn die
kampfhandlungen verlagern sich jetzt
immer mehr sie konzentrieren sich auf
den osten und den südosten des landes
also auch in küstenregionen und die
mosca ist ein schiff das durchaus über
eine erhebliche feuerkraft verfügt und
diese stünden dann eben nicht mehr zur
verfügung das ist übrigens auch die
einschätzung des nationalen
sicherheitsberaters der usa solle wenn
der sagt der verlust dieses schiffes
also wenn dieses schiff tatsächlich
nicht mehr eingesetzt werden könnte dann
wäre das ein schwerer dämpfer für
russland
ukraine und nicht nur sie ja in den
nächsten tagen eine großoffensive vor
allem im osten
genauso ist es nach ukrainischen angaben
scheint es auch so zu sein dass die
vorbereitung für eine solche offensive
bereits weitgehend abgeschlossen sind
also man geht hier in der ukraine ganz
offenbar davon aus dass der angriff also
ein größerer angriff unmittelbar
bevorsteht der ukrainische präsident
seelands gesagt dass die russischen
streitkräfte zehntausende von soldaten
in der region zusammenziehen und selen
ski hat in den vergangenen wochen oder
vielmehr tagen immer wieder massiv war
dieser offensive gewarnt hat vor allem
waffenlieferungen eingefordert vor allem
das liefern von schweren waffen auch von
deutschland damit eben die ukraine in
die lage versetzt sich gegen diese
offensive zu werden im moment geht es
vor allem darum noch so viele menschen
wie möglich aus diesen potentiellen
kampfzonen herauszuholen also sie zu
evakuieren und ukrainische offizielle
sagen dass diese schlacht um dem don was
womöglich an den zweiten weltkrieg
erinnern könnte ganze städte könnten
zerstört werden und die ukrainische
seite hat massive gegenwehr angekündigt
es könnte also sein dass dieser krieg da
er ohnehin schon seit wochen so
unerbittlich geführt wird dass er
nochmals in eine neue phase eintritt und
zwar in eine wesentlich brutalere und
härtere phase da geschehen nach kiew ja
in der tat die ukraine bittet vor allem
um schwere waffen um sich nämlich nicht
nur zu verteidigen sondern die russen
auch zurückbringen zu können
dafür genügen gewehre panzerfäuste oder
geländewagen nicht dafür braucht es
schweres gerät also panzer flugzeuge
kriegsschiffe großkalibrige
flugabwehrsysteme mehrere länder liefern
das auch bereits die usa haben gerade
eine neue 800 millionen dollar liste
veröffentlicht auf der schwere waffen
stehen estland hat haubitzen geliefert
also schwere artilleriegeschütze polen
und tschechien haben kanzler geschickt
die slowakei ist bereit mit kampfjets zu
liefern derweil geht in deutschland die
politische debatte weiter wie thomas
reich berichtet in einer halle in
flensburg steht viel von dem was die
ukraine im krieg gegen russland gerne
hätte von der bundesregierung aber
bislang nicht bekam eingeparkt rund 100
leopard 1 kampfpanzer außerdem 60 panzer
moerser m 113 sowie brücken und
pionierpanzer von der bundeswehr
ausgemustert aber noch gut verwendbar
für die ukraine
wir haben sowieso auch bedarf an den
bergepanzer die sie gerade hinter mir
sehen aber auch an den leopard 1 die
hier auch vor ort sind in flensburg und
zur verfügung stellen könnten die in
wenigen wochen das panzer lager in
flensburg gehört der firma ffg die
spezialisiert darauf ist altes gerät
wieder herzurichten kurz nach putins
angriff partners
verteidigungsministerium auch die ffg um
eine liste was sie der ukraine liefern
könnten die fertige liste ging nach
berlin ans ministerium anfang märz war
das seitdem hat die fsg nichts mehr
gehört trotz der hilferufe aus kiew
herrscht schweigen in berlin der
bundeskanzler hat ja gesagt dass er
sowohl die bundeswehr modernisieren will
aber eben auch die ukraine unterstützen
das muss dann jetzt konsequent umgesetzt
werden das darf auch nicht in der
verwaltung dann wochenlang dauern denn
der krieg geht weiter wir müssen hier
schneller werden und auch die
bundesregierung muss hier schnell zu
entscheidungen kommen in berlin wächst
so die kritik am kanzler scholz der
druck wie andré nato staaten auch
schwere waffen zu liefern
das liegt im bundeskanzleramt olaf
scholz steht auf der bremse er will das
ganz offensichtlich nicht und erlebt
damit eine große verantwortung auf sich
seine belastung für deutschland
insgesamt
er hilft der ukraine nicht so wie es
möglich wäre die kritik kommt längst
auch aus den reihen der ampel von
abgeordneten etwa die kürzlich selbst in
die ukraine reisten mit verzweifelten
parlamentariern dort sprachen und wieder
listen bekamen was die ukraine alles
brauche waffen zum beispiel wie sie in
flensburg stehen doch wie zerrissen
insbesondere die spd in der frage ist
zeigt sich heute die abgeordneten
delegation wird abgekanzelt vom
fraktionsvorsitzenden sich vor ort ein
bild zu machen kann richtig sein unter
diesem eindruck allerdings bisher
beispiellose entscheidungen zu fordern
ohne sie selbst verantworten zu müssen
ist falsch zumal diese weitgehende
konsequenzen für die sicherheit unseres
landes und der nato haben könnten
doch fdp grüne und teile der spd drängen
weiter auf eine kursänderung jedenfalls
dann wenn noch mehr nato staaten
mitmachen es gibt bisher zwei länder die
gepanzerte fahrzeuge geliefert haben das
sind polen und tschechien und zwar
russischer bauart alle anderen nato
staaten haben das nicht getan wenn es
eine veränderung der linie gibt muss sie
gemeinsam und geschlossen erfolgen vor
der russischen botschaft legen
ukrainische flüchtlinge heute babypuppen
auf dem boden fordern rettet unsere
kinder eine anklage gegenüber russland
und ein hilferuf an deutschland
ja noch ein aktueller nachtrag jetzt
eben in diesem moment kam eine meldung
der nachrichtenagentur
reuters dem entstehen nach hat der
russische verteidigungsminister gesagt
dass die moskwa also das kriegsschiff
gesunken sein das entspreche dann dem
was die ukraine ja von anfang an schon
gesagt haben aber es ist im moment wie
gesagt nur eine quelle da muss man noch
ein bisschen vorsichtig sein
direkt nach amtsantritt mit einem
solchen krieg konfrontiert zu werden das
wünscht man jedenfalls keine regierung
die grünen hat das bislang aber nicht
geschadet im gegenteil über tabak und
annalena baerbock haben an popularität
kräftig zugelegt anders als spd und fdp
mussten sie ja auch keine politischen
kehrtwenden in der einschätzung von
russland oder nord stream zwei
vollführen und obwohl harbeck als
wirtschaftsminister in kriegszeiten
jetzt plötzlich dinge tun muss die ein
grüner eigentlich nicht will ist er zum
beliebtesten deutschen politiker
aufgestiegen
so gesehen lief es für die grünen seit
amtsantritt also eigentlich sehr gut bis
das debakel und familienministerin anne
spiegel kann ihre nachfolgerin soll das
jetzt schnell vergessen machen mathis
feldhoff stellt sie vor
wie war die große überraschung die die
keiner auf dem zettel hatte aber bei
ihrer vorstellung hinterlässt lisa paus
am nachmittag den eindruck dass sie
eigentlich so etwas wie die natürliche
wahl ist natürlich musste ich erst mal
drüber nachdenken das war jetzt erst mal
nicht mein plan ja
aber ich habe dann kurz darüber
nachgedacht und habe dann festgestellt
ganz ehrlich ich bin zu den grünen
gekommen weil ich feministin bin ich
habe aus tiefster überzeugung und mit
sehr viel engagement dafür gekämpft dass
die kindergrundsicherung ein
kernbestandteil grüner sozial und
kinderpolitik ist als eine der
architektinnen dieser kinder
grundsicherung soll die gelernte
finanzpolitikerin eine erfahrene
parlamentarierin die seit 2009 im
bundestag sitzt jetzt dass frauen und
familienministerium führen ein
ministerium das den grünen besonders
wichtig ist wir wissen wie groß die
herausforderungen die aufgaben in dieser
zeit sind es ist das zentrale
ministerium für gesellschaftspolitik
über das wir sprechen lisa paus scheint
perfekt in das anforderungsprofil der
grünen zu passen frau vom linken flügel
und kompetent so hatte es der
bundesvorstand formuliert und sie
unterscheidet sich von ihrer vorgängerin
anne spiegel denn post kennt das
berliner parkett und seine härte
sie bringt leidenschaft mit insbesondere
für soziale themen für kinderarmut für
seniorinnen und senioren für die
menschen in diesem land und genau danach
entschieden ob auch olaf scholz so
erfreut ist über die wahl wird er wohl
für sich behalten jedenfalls sind seine
erinnerungen an die letzte begegnung mit
lisa paus vor dem more card
untersuchungsausschuss nicht ganz so
ungetrübt auf einem halben jahr war paus
der meinung scholz sei als
finanzminister überfordert es steht eben
nach wie vor im raum dass die behörde
falsch gearbeitet hat klar ist dass olaf
scholz seine behörde nicht im griff hat
jetzt wo scholz nicht nur chef der
finanzbehörden ist sondern sogar chef
der ganzen regierung wollen dass beide
lieber wieder vergessen jetzt freue ich
mich auf die konstruktive und
erfolgreiche zusammenarbeit ich habe
auch bereits mit ihm telefoniert und ich
kann sagen wir freuen uns beide lisa
paus muss jetzt die größte krise der
grünen seit regierungsbeginn im letzten
jahr vergessen machen eine krise die an
den grundfragen kratzte dem vertrauen
und der solidität von politik
und jetzt erstmal die nachrichten von
heinz wolf erneut sorgt in den usa ein
polizeieinsatz für empörung bei dem ein
junger schwarzer ums leben gekommen ist
die polizei von grand rapids in michigan
hat jetzt videos von dem vorfall von vor
zehn tagen veröffentlichen demnach kommt
es nach einer aus dem ruder gelaufenen
verkehrskontrolle zu einer
auseinandersetzung in deren verlauf der
polizist den mann in den kopf schießt
laut polizei läuft die untersuchung noch
der polizist sei derzeit beurlaubt
der britische premierminister johnson
treibt trotz scharfer kritik von
bürgerrechtlern und der opposition seine
pläne voran migranten für die dauer
ihres asylantrags nach woanders
auszufliegen mit dem ostafrikanischen
land sei eine entsprechende vereinbarung
getroffen worden sagte johnson damit
versucht die regierung nach eigenen
angaben
wirtschaftsflüchtlinge von der
gefährlichen und illegalen überfahrt
über den ärmelkanal abzuschrecken und
menschenhändlern das handwerk zu legen
in südafrika dauert die suche nach
überlebenden nach den verheerenden
überschwemmungen an die zahl der
todesopfer ist auch mehr als 300
gestiegen dutzende weitere menschen
werden immer noch vermisst viele
gegenden sind ohne strom und fließendes
wasser ungewöhnlich heftige regenfälle
hatten vor allem im großraum durban
schwere überflutungen und erdrutsche
ausgelöst
dass es sich bei der sogenannten
querdenker szene nicht nur um harmlose
zeitgenossen mit eigenwilligen weltbild
handelt das ist schon lange offenkundig
dem verfassungsschutz ist auch nicht
entgangen wie sich kroner leugner und
rechtsextreme reichs bürger vermengten
spätestens beim versuchten sturm auf den
reichstag dürfte dem letzten klar
geworden sein dass sich hier leute
versammelten denen es keineswegs nur
darum ging die notwendigkeit des maske
tragens infrage zu stellen in mehreren
bundesländern gab es umfängliche razzien
und eine gruppe männer und frauen wurde
festgenommen sie sollen
sprengstoffanschläge die entführung des
bundesgesundheitsministers und den sturz
der regierung geplant haben susanne
gelhard und christopher hein zu
berichten
es waren keine spinner am werk sondern
gefährliche kriminelle die so genannte
jet gruppe vereinte patrioten plante
stromausfälle durch sprengstoffanschläge
um mit chaos und bürgerkriegsähnlichen
zuständen in deutschland die macht zu
übernehmen und die demokratie zu
beseitigen hier ist diese schwelle in
die reale welt überschritten worden es
gab ja ganz konkrete pläne den
bundesminister für gesundheit zu
entführen und wir haben geglaubt die
schwelle
zur zur vorbereitung dieser tat ist in
dem moment überschritten wo es darum
gehen die waffen zu besorgen und sie
auch daneben zu kaufen mit diesen waffen
sollte auch der personenschutz des
gesundheitsministers getötet werden der
ganze vorgang zeigt dass sich die krone
proteste nicht nur radikalisiert haben
hier geht es also um kräfte die eine
also absicht haben auch den staats- und
die demokratie zu destabilisieren nutzen
offenbar die korona proteste ist eine
kleine minderheit in der gesellschaft
aber hochgefährlich meine eigene arbeit
wird das nicht beeinflussen ich werde
weitermachen wie bisher über den
messenger dienst telegrammen verbreitete
die gruppe umsturzpläne seit vorbereitet
es kann jetzt jeden tag losgehen nettes
marschbefehl wenn ihr wollt das system
muss weg wie der herr lauterbach no wir
lassen uns als demokratinnen demokraten
davon einschüchtern wir werden nach wie
vor hart daran arbeiten die demokratie
zu schützen es hat jetzt noch mal
gezeigt dass solche hacks kommentare das
in chats bei telegramm solche äußerungen
getätigt werden das rechtfertigt aus
meiner sicht das harte vorgehen gegen
diese plattform bei razzien in neun
bundesländern wurden gestern vier
personen festgenommen insgesamt wird
gegen zwölf ermittelt die
hauptverdächtigen ein 55 jähriger aus
neustadt an der weinstraße und ein 54
jähriger aus falkensee bei berlin
insgesamt es ist aus meiner sicht
bedeutsam dass wir es hier mit einer
melos zu tun haben
bestehende aus verschwörungstheoretikern
impfgegnern aber auch preis bürgern die
wir einstehen dieser form bisher nicht
festgestellt hatten das scheint mir
dieser gruppen ist tatsächlich von einer
gemeinsam geteilten paranoiden
vorstellung geprägt die im grunde besagt
die da oben und auch große teile der
bevölkerung dadurch dass sie mitmachen
in der gesellschaft im system sind
eigentlich teil des problems sind das
problem das es zu überwinden gilt den
ermittlungsteams in mainz und im
bundesgebiet ist heute ein wichtiger
schlag gelungen gegen eine neue art von
bedrohung die alle treffen kann und
noch schnell eine aktualisierung auch
die dpa meldet jetzt mit berufung auf
die russische nachrichtenagentur tass
der russische regierung bestätigt ja
kein kriegsschiff moskwa ist gesunken
die ukraine würden sagen es wurde
versucht
dem wechsel nicht nur ökonomen haben
heute mit spannung nach frankfurt
geblickt wird die ezb die europäische
zentralbank die leitzinsen anheben
spoiler nein das tat sie nicht sie
bleibt erstmal weiter bei ihrer
nullzinspolitik viele hatten auf einer
zinserhöhung gehofft und sie
aufgefordert immerhin haben wir im euro
raum inzwischen eine inflationsrate von
siebeneinhalb prozent
allerdings stehen die europäischen
währungshüter vor einem heiklen problem
die aktuelle inflation wird von
preisanstiegen auf der güter seite
getrieben also auf der angebotsseite
etwa durch teures öl und gas dagegen
kann die ezb über ihre geldpolitik nicht
viel tun das macht die sache nicht
einfacher für die notenbank nicht und
auch nicht für die wirtschaft peter
wagner richtet
christian kirchhübel ist verantwortlich
für 630 mitarbeitende in aller welt 450
davon in wetzlar dort produziert der
familienbetrieb oculus seit 125 jahren
vor allem präzisionsinstrumente für
ärzte und optiker bester deutscher
mittelstand umsatz deutlich über 100
millionen euro im jahr die hohe
inflation macht dem chef sorgen
unternehmerische entscheidungen werden
schwierig wenn das preisniveau stabil
ist dann können wir berechenbar
investitionen planen wenn das
preisniveau wurden nicht stabil ist das
ist so wie wenn sie fahrrad fahren und
haben eine augenbinde auf die preise
kennen nur eine richtung kraftstoffe im
jahresvergleich plus 50 prozent gas + 42
wer frisches gemüse sucht zahlt 15
prozent mehr insgesamt steigt die
inflationsrate im märz auf 7,3 prozent
höchster stand seit 1990 stabile preise
sehen anders aus
preisstabilität ist die wichtigste
aufgabe der europäischen zentralbank
doch die ezb heizt das inflations feuer
durch staatsanleihenkäufe noch an die
ezb hat ein problem und das problem ist
dass sie die inflation viel zu lange
ignoriert hat und sich nur darauf
konzentriert hat die zinsen niedrig zu
halten um die finanzierungsbedingungen
für alle europäischen länder günstig zu
machen und jetzt ist das kind in den
brunnen gefallen das kind wird auch noch
eine weile im boden bleiben keine
überraschungen heute bei der ezb
präsident in lagarde zurzeit corona
positiv macht die pressekonferenz aus
dem homeoffice im dritten quartal könnte
sich die geldpolitik endlich ändern
deutet sie vorsichtig an
die reise hat also bereits begonnen und
sie geht weiter wie vorhergesagt im
durchschnitt 7,5 prozent inflation ist
deutlich zu hoch die ezb ist in der
zwickmühle
durch den russischen überfall auf die
ukraine sind rohstoffpreise weltweit
massiv gestiegen die lok downs in
shanghai und anderswo in china gefährden
aufs neue die internationalen
lieferketten erhöht die bank die zinsen
um die inflation zu senken könnte die
wirtschaft leiden was losigkeit drohen
und für hoch verschuldete euro-länder
könnte die staatsfinanzierung plötzlich
teurer werden die ezb spricht in ihrer
kommunikation immer wieder von den
finanzierungskosten insbesondere den
finanzierungskosten der staaten die sind
extrem niedrig die möchte sie niedrig
halten aber die inflation hat priorität
die muss bekämpft werden da muss man die
zinsen erhöhen und das können die
staaten auch verkraften ich halte
befürchtungen dass die staaten das nicht
verkraften können wenn die ezb den zins
normalisiert für übertrieben auch wenn
die ezb demnächst einmal die zinswende
einleiten sollte ansteigende preise
werden wir uns noch längere zeit
gewöhnen müssen
und zu hause und da heute mal zunächst
der blick auf die us börse und die
aktien von tesla und twitter wie kommt
das angebot von tesla chef elon musk an
sina mainitz ja an der new yorker börse
wird das mehr als skeptisch gesehen
sowohl bei der twitter als auch bei der
tesla aktie ist gerade die luft raus
sollte elon musk mit seinen plänen
durchkommen die nachrichtendienst
twitter komplett zu kaufen könnte selbst
er als reichster mann der welt das nicht
aus der portokasse bezahlen er müsste
anteile seines elektroautohersteller
tesla verkaufen der wert der tesla aktie
verliert an der new yorker börse heute
bisher mehr als drei prozent erst vor
gut zwei wochen ist elon musk bei
twitter eingestiegen und mit einem
anteil von 9,2 prozent bereits größter
einzelaktionär
er hat mehr als 80 millionen follower
und ist dort selbst einer der aktivsten
nutzer einen posten im verwaltungsrat
lehnte er erst kürzlich ab denn mit
dieser mitgliedschaft hätte er seinen
anteil nicht erhöhen können und musk
will ganz offensichtlich seine macht in
den sozialen medien ausbauen twitter hat
ein außergewöhnliches potenzial ich
werde es freisetzen
übermass übernahmepläne muss nun der
aufsichtsrat entscheiden ein
großaktionär hat schon angekündigt bei
dem vorhaben nicht mitzumachen twitter
selbst will die pläne aufmerksam prüfen
sollte mast mit seinem vorstoß
erfolgreich sein bild twitter von der
börse nehmen weil der dienst nur so das
potenzial als plattform für redefreiheit
ausschöpfen könne sagt er
muskelspiele auch an der frankfurter
börse der dax geht leicht gestärkt ins
lange osterwochenende sind am main jetzt
vielen dank
allen ergebnis aus der
fußball-europa-league rb leipzig hat bei
atalanta bergamo das viertelfinal
rückspiel mit 2 0 gewonnen und damit
steht leipzig erstmals im halbfinale der
europa league
bundeswirtschaftsminister habeck will
die staatliche förderung von plug in
hybridautos ende 2022 streichen laut
wirtschaftsministerium sein plug in
hybridautos jetzt marktgängig und
benötigten keine öffentliche förderung
mehr umweltverbände kritisierten die
kaufprämie für plug-in-hybride seit
langem da diese vor allem im suv-segment
angeboten und überwiegend nicht
elektrisch gefahren würden
jetzt die osterferien und am horizont
winkt schon der sommer hoffentlich mit
niedrigeren instanzen irgendwann kommt
dann aber auch wieder der herbst und da
schwant schon vielen dass das kroner
mäßig wieder übel werden könnte
schlimmstenfalls sogar wieder mit
zugangsbeschränkungen home office oder
sogar homeschooling ob sich bis dahin
dann alle schulen und büros in
deutschland in digital fit gemacht haben
da darf man zweifel haben
insofern ist es schon bemerkenswert wie
die flüchtlinge aus der ukraine uns
gerade ihren stand der digitalisierung
vor augen führen schulunterricht fernab
der heimat zumindest technisch ist das
kein problem sein
papa ist elf seine familie ist aus der
zentral ukraine geflohen 100 kilometer
von den umkämpften gebieten im osten
entfernt schon während der flucht und
auch jetzt in der nähe von hamburg hat
pascha online unterricht
mama hat dann an einem tag gesagt dass
wir wegmüssen erst nach polen und als
wir einen halben tag da waren nach
deutschland die hälfte meiner klasse ist
dagegen
die lehrerinnen sind ebenfalls da
geblieben in krobnitz sie unterrichten
von zu hause immer wieder müssen sie den
unterricht unterbrechen luftalarm
an manchen tagen haben wir fünf mal
luftalarm manchmal gar nicht erzählt
maria melda akbas als englischlehrerin
wir laufen dann in die schutzbunker
heute konnte ich alle stunden mit meinen
kindern abhalten wir sind weit gekommen
dann kam doch wieder luftalarm
passat macht dann im sicheren
deutschland hausaufgaben seine mutter
larissa sitzt im rollstuhl
sie konnte nicht mit in die luft
schutzbunker auch deshalb ist die
familie sehr früh geflohen
wir haben eine lange flucht gehabt in
turnhallen und schulen geschlafen für
pascha war das eine schlimme zeit jetzt
ist er glücklich manche seiner
klassenkameraden sind sogar neidisch
dass er hier im schönen deutschland sein
kann
auch tatjana wodka ist geflohen aus
lavive sie ist lehrerin und wollte ihre
kinder an einem hamburger gymnasium
anmelden der schulleiter nahm sie gleich
mit dazu jetzt unterrichtet sie eine
internationale willkommens klasse auch
mit ihren eigenen kindern
am fernunterricht aus der ukraine nehmen
die kinder aus ihrer klasse nicht mehr
teil die schule hat ein rein
ukrainisches angebot am nachmittag für
die kinder eine neue gemeinschaft pascha
wird noch diese woche aus der ukraine
unterrichtet dann wechselt auch eher an
eine deutsche schule mit guten
startvoraussetzungen er lernt deutsch
als zweite fremdsprache bereits seit
einem dreiviertel jahr
ich komme aus sie gut ausgebildet
mit lernwilligen kindern geht es gleich
auch weiter in unserem neuen zdf format
don't stop the music und wir beide
melden uns morgen wieder und wieder
sehen
[Musik]
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter das ist der blick
von der internationalen raumstation auf
unserer atmosphäre und was wir hier
sehen ist auf dem pazifik ein wunderbar
ausgeprägtes tief was wir aber noch
sehen ist dass die atmosphäre sehr sehr
dünn ist und diese sehr schmale schicht
das ist der bereich wo sich das wetter
abspielt was uns quasi vom weltraum
trend und dieser zehn kilometer in dem
das wetter geschieht das verschmutzen
wir mit treibhausgasen schauen wir auf
das aktuelle wetter und da tropft das
hoch von skandinavien allmählich weiter
nach süden nach deutschland und es gibt
zweigeteiltes wetter im westen europas
ist es deutlich wärmer als im osten und
das stellt sich folgendermaßen dar 5 bis
10 grad nach osten hin 20 bis 30 grad zb
richtung iberische halbinsel
in der nacht gibt es einzelne schauer
nach osten hin mehr regen im süden und
im westen lockert es auf bei
temperaturen von 4 bis 10 grad morgen
dann im osten dicht bewölkt mit etwas
sprühregen
es lässt aber dann allmählich nach oder
auch an den alpen gibt es schauer die
werden auch weniger sonst aber sonnige
abschnitte die höchsten temperaturen von
acht bis 13 grad in der nordosthälfte
und 13 bis 21 grad in der südwesthälfte
kommenden tage über ostern weiterhin
sonniges wetter im osten eher kühler als
im westen bei neun bis 18 grad am
samstag und ostermontag 10 bis 19 grad
ein schöner abend